The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation, or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right.
So here's the box score from
the celebration on Monday.
Class average improved
considerably.
A number of people moved
from the sad face
to the smiley face.
I would still tell anybody who
is down over here that the
final exam is coming, and if you
perform well on the final
exam, we'll take a look
at the overall
performance of the semester.
So get in and talk to us, if
you want to, to see what we
can do to help you
succeed here.
But it takes a little bit of
effort on your part as well.
I think that's all
I want to say.
There will be a weekly test, a
weekly minor celebration on
Tuesday, as normal.
So today we're going to start
the last of two units.
We have two units left before
the end of the semester.
And this one is biochemistry.
And it's one of these
integrative topics that's
going to bring together a lot
of the material that we've
looked at in the past.
And biochemistry overview, it's
the chemistry of living
organisms. And the first thing
to point out is that
biochemistry is governed by the
same laws that apply to
inanimate matter.
And apropos of that, I'd like
to read something that was
written by the Nobel Prize
winner, Richard Feynman.
"If in some cataclysm, all of
scientific knowledge were to
be destroyed, and only one
sentence passed on to the next
generations of creatures, what
statement would contain the
most information in
the fewest words?
I believe that it is the atomic
hypothesis, or the
atomic factor, whatever you
wish to call it, that all
things are made of atoms. Little
particles that move
around in perpetual motion,
attracting each other when
they are a little distance
apart, but repelling upon
being squeezed into
one another."
So that's the first thing
to point out.
That it's the same chemistry
that we've been
learning up until now.
And in fact, I think I've got a
a slide that captures the--
there's the Feynman quote,
the last part of it.
Second thing is, by way of
introduction, you see a boom
around us today in biotech.
And what is the biotech?
It's the molecular biology, it's
the commercialization of
molecular biology.
Biology, when I was your age,
was classification, taxonomy,
naming things and figuring out
what bin they fit into.
Today it's not that.
It's molecular biology.
Well, what's the molecular
science?
Molecular science is chemistry,
and it's solid
state chemistry.
Biology is solid state
chemistry.
We are solid state devices made
of soft matter with an
endoskeleton that's ceramic,
and so on.
But we are solid
state devices.
So this is solid state chemistry
and material
science, and that's why we
talk about it in 3.091.
And why now?
Why is the biochem revolution
only now?
Well, it has to do
with complexity.
You can think about complexity
from the standpoint of
materials, and in fact, lay
out the ages of man.
The Stone Age.
The Stone Age precedes
the Bronze Age.
Why?
Because stone is found
in nature naturally.
To use stone requires only to
cut it and change its shape.
But you make bronze, you have
to engage in chemical
processing.
There's a chemical conversion
that requires a higher level
of societal sophistication.
And then iron follows bronze.
Why?
Because iron melts at a higher
temperature, so you have to
have a higher level of
technology in order to make
the furnaces and to conduct
the reduction reaction to
extract iron.
And then comes polymers.
Polymers, the birth of
synthetics, come when?
First polymers were around,
what, 1829, when the
pharmacist was playing
with the styrene.
And then it explodes in
the 20th century.
And then mid-century
we get silicon.
And silicon is even more
sophisticated, because we had
to understand quantum mechanics
to even understand
that we needed silicon.
We could convert beach sand into
silicon back in 1500, but
who knew what to do with
silicon in 1500?
And then finally comes the end
of the 20th century, and now
we're dealing with this stuff.
So that sort of puts things
in perspective.
So what we're going to do today
is start the treatment
of biomolecules.
And the first thing I want to
say, is we're going to be
talking about macromolecules
but not polymers.
So all polymers are
macromolecules, but all
macromolecules are
not polymers.
What's the difference?
In polymers, we have a common
repeat unit, whereas in the
life sciences, Mother
Nature is a polymer
engineer gone wild.
She takes different functional
groups and puts them at every
stage along the way, as opposed
to polyethylene, where
it is the same functional
group at every stop.
So it is exploded polymer
chemistry,
macromolecular chemistry.
So there's four classifications
of
biomolecules.
The proteins, carbohydrates,
lipids, nucleic acids.
And we're going to look
at three of the four.
We'll start today
with proteins.
We will study lipids and nucleic
acids, but in the time
allowed, we're going
to lose the sugars.
So you'll take 7.012 or
something to satisfy the
Institute biology requirement,
you'll go much
more deeply into it.
But I think you're going to
have very good preparation
after three lectures here, and
you'll be able to put together
a lot of the material that
we've looked at prior.
So the first thing we're going
to look at is proteins.
Proteins are macromolecules,
and they're formed by
polymerization of monomers
known as amino acids.
So before we can talk about
proteins, we're going to first
look at amino acids.
So let's do that.
And amino acids are substances
that have the following
skeletal structure.
I'm going to start a
new board for this.
So this is the basic skeletal
structure of the amino acid.
It's got a central carbon,
sp3 hybridized with
four struts on it.
Down in the lower left corner,
we have the amino group, which
is nitrogen and two hydrogens.
So there's one, two, three bonds
off the nitrogen, and I
want to emphasize but it's still
got this unpaired set of
electrons, which we know makes
this thing a Bronsted base.
And it's going to have a site
here for proton attachment.
And that's a big feature
here in amino acids.
So this is the amino group.
And it acts as a
Bronsted base.
So it's a proton attachment
site.
Second strut is hydrogen
in every amino acid.
The third site, over here, is
the carboxylic acid end, and
that's carbon with a double
bond, and one, two, three,
four, all right?
Every carbon needs four
struts, and the
fourth one has the OH.
And this is the H that
can fall off.
So this is the proton
donor here.
This is carboxylic acid end.
So this is three of the four
ends of the carbon bonds are
fixed in all amino acids.
And then the fourth one is
free to be specified.
This is all R.
R is a placeholder.
It stands for the substituent.
This is the substituent.
And this is nature's choice.
So you can put anything here.
There are hundreds
of amino acids.
There are only 20
seen in protein.
But anything that goes up here,
with this structure, is
an amino acid.
I don't care.
You could put a cyanide up
here, for all I care.
It'll still qualify as a amino
acid if these other three
sites are filled in the
following matter.
So 20 seen in amino acids.
20 of those in amino acids.
And now I want to look at the
substituents and break those
into categories.
So there's four categories
of substituents.
In other words, the 20 here
can be broken into four
categories.
Four categories of R.
And we can group those by their
chemical properties.
The first group, I took this
from one of the other texts.
Yeah, this is from one
of the other texts.
So there's the 20 amino acids.
So I'm now highlighting some of
the ones that are nonpolar.
So what do you see there?
The nonpolar ones,
you see for R.
The R group is above here.
so?
This is just plain hydrogen,
which is nonpolar There's a
methyl group, CH3, so
that's alanine.
Here's a methylene with two
methyls, so this is alanine,
and so on and so forth.
So the different groups
hang off that R
position at the top.
So these are nonpolar, and this
also is characterized by
being hydrophobic.
So that end becomes hydrophobic
when we use
nonpolar group.
The second option is to have
polar substituents.
And some of them even have
hydrogen bonding capability.
That's the second category.
And of course those are going
to be hydrophilic.
The third group is charged.
The third group actually has a
charge end, which becomes a
negative ion in aqueous
solution.
And these are going to be
strongly hydrophilic.
And also--
[BREAK IN VIDEO]
PROFESSOR: Number nine, number
nine, number nine.
Can you hear?
Yes?
Yeah, that's good.
Hydrophilic and acidic.
The acoustics here today are
very different, huh?
We're missing a few bodies.
We need to put the crash test
dummies in here, and then
we'll have the same
acoustic sound.
All right.
And then the fourth category
gives you a cation, R plus, in
aqueous solution, which
then, strongly
hydrophilic and basic.
So we'll go through.
Now, our bodies can synthesize
only 10 of the 20 amino acids,
and then the other 10 we
have to get from diets.
So when you look at some of
these fad diets, you might
want to check and make sure
you're getting all of the
proper nutrients.
Now another of the structural
features of amino acids that's
important is chirality.
Chirality is a feature
of amino acids.
And what is chirality?
I'll show you by
way of example.
Chirality talks about
handedness.
Comes from the Greek
word for glove.
So let me show you molecules
that have the chirality that
distinguishes them.
So I'm going to give an
example with alanine.
With alanine, the R-substituent
group is equal
to the methyl, CH3.
So I'm going to put CH3 up here
for the substituent, and
then the other three stations
are as we know them to be.
So there's the amino group,
there's the hydrogen, and
here's the carboxylic acid.
And note, look at the compact
notation here.
We write COOH.
This O is not bonded to
the O next to it.
Both O's are bonded to
the carbon, but this
is compressed notation.
COOH, and then this.
So this is alanine, and I could
just as easily write the
molecule in the following
manner.
I would still satisfy the
requirement that I have an
amino group, a hydrogen group,
a carboxylic acid group.
Actually, if I want to get
really fancy in chemistry, I
could write it this way.
COOH, and everybody knows H
can't bond to two species.
In fact, it's the carbon here.
But it's OK.
It's compressed and in the
methyl group up here.
And what you notice is that the
molecule on the left is
distinguishable from the
molecule on the right.
These are not the same molecule,
even though the same
substituents are here, and the
other features are preserved.
This cannot be superimposed.
So you could distinguish
these two.
If I just threw them on the
floor, you'd be able to pick
them up and say, one has
the amino group in this
orientation, and if I put the
other one, with the methyl
above and the hydrogen below, I
will have the amino group on
the other side.
And these things also are
optically active.
And through their optical
activity, we
give them their names.
And so let's take a look here.
All right.
This is just a little bit
more of the amino acids.
And actually, one of our former
3.091 TAs, Andrew
Magyar, who just defended
his PhD thesis.
I was on his committee, and he
did a splendid job, and used
his 3.091 principles to get
through his advanced biology.
This is a list which is going
to be part of the PDF that
I'll post. But there are 20
amino acids, and as you know,
there are 26 letters in the
alphabet we use in English.
And so if you want to write them
in compressed form, you
just use one of these letters.
There's the three-letter
notation as
well, so ALA is alanine.
And in the past, I used to have
contests in 3.091 to ask
students to give me the
airports, if these were
three-letter airport codes.
You see, it always comes around
Thanksgiving, and
people are busy heading to--
and it turns out that 19 of
the 20 amino acids have
airport codes that correspond to
the amino acid three-letter
abbreviations, with the
exception of glutamine, GLN.
There's no airport that
has GLN as its thing.
That's a piece of trivia that
will get you the last wedge in
Trivial Pursuit.
And then this is the one-letter
abbreviation.
So Andrew has put them
in this form.
So there again, I have the
basic, the acidic, the
aliphatic are the ones
that are nonpolar.
And this is another
way to look at it.
And here's the base structure,
and here's the whole thing in
monochrome.
All right.
So that's part of the thing.
OK.
So here's what I'm
talking about.
The mirror plane.
So this box can be mirrored
as shown.
But as soon as you put a
distinguishing mark in the
lower right-hand corner here,
the box on the left is not
superimposable to the
box on the right.
They are distinguishable.
And so these things will
have different chemical
reactivities, not melting point
boiling point, but how
they react with other
molecules.
So here's the chirologics.
Your gloves are chiral.
If you try to put your
right-handed glove on your
left hand, it's a poor
fit, whereas the
flask here is achiral.
And now here are some molecules,
just to show you
how this translates
into chemistry.
So this molecule is chiral, this
molecule is not chiral.
And it has to do with the number
of positions that are
distinguishable.
And how does this fit into the
grand scheme of things?
It's sort of a form of
stereoisomerism, isn't it?
Remember, we looked at the
geometric isomers.
Here's an example.
This is dichloroethylene.
We looked at butene.
But here we've got cis-isomer,
here we've got the
trans-isomer, where the
chlorines are on opposite
sides of the double bond here.
They're on the same side of
the double bond here.
These are types of
optical isomers.
These are the mirror images,
the same functional groups,
but in this case, in one
orientation, the plus
enantiomer, here's the
minus enantiomer.
They're called enantiomers
because it comes from the
Greek word for mirror.
So we're using the Greek word
for glove and the Greek word
for mirror.
Now we'll talk about the optical
activity, and then
we'll take a few notes.
So what's the optical
activity?
It turns out that if you put
these in aqueous solution,
they will cause the
polarization
vector of light to rotate.
So here's a cartoon that shows
a light source with
unpolarized light, and then
the light goes through a
polarizer, which then
forces only
vertically polarized light.
In other words, the electric
factor is in the vertical
orientation.
And so now this electric
vector enters this tube
containing an aqueous solution
of something
that has optical activity.
And the degree of rotation is
proportional, obviously, to
the concentration of the chiral
species, and also the
path length.
So if you have a dilute solution
on a long path, or a
concentrated solution on a short
path, it's the number of
collisions.
And ultimately, you have a
degree of rotation, et cetera.
And so based on how the electric
vector changes is how
we got the names for the various
enantiomers, because
we've got to name
them somehow.
Otherwise we can't distinguish
one from the other.
So it turns out that the way
I've drawn this one, with the
amino group in the lower right,
and the carboxylic acid
group in the lower left, causes
the electric vector to
rotate clockwise.
So I'm going to write h nu, just
so that you know, or if
you want to put the electric
vector or something.
It rotates page to the right,
and so the Latin word for
right is dexter.
So this is called
dextrorotatory.
This is the dextrorotatory
enantiomer.
So now you've got really nice
terminology to use at the
table over the Thanksgiving
turkey, all right?
So this is the D-form, D-circle,
or, as every
right-handed person knows when
speaking to a left-handed
person, this is the positive
direction, OK?
And now this one causes
an anti-clockwise, or
counterclockwise rotation
of light in an
aqueous solution of this.
And rather than use sinister,
which is the Latin word for
left, and it has all these
negative connotations, they
went to the Slavic, and
shows levorotatory.
So this is levorotatory, L-form,
or minus N, with
apologies to the left-handed
people in the audience.
That's what it's called.
OK.
So these are called enantiomers,
and hence, you
understand the choice
of Man in the Mirror
for the opening music.
So 19 of the 20 amino
acids are chiral.
The only one that's non-chiral,
the only
non-chiral amino acid,
is glycine.
Glycine has hydrogen
as a substituent.
So now you have hydrogens above
and below, an amino acid
here, and carboxylic
acid here.
And this one is achiral.
This is achiral.
So the other 19 so that's 95%
of the amino acids, are
chiral, and they exhibit this
interesting behavior.
Now the other interesting
piece is that only the
L-enantiomer--
by and large, there a few
exceptions that you can find.
There's some research
on this, trying to
find, always the exception.
But by and large, only the
L-enantiomer of amino acids
are found in proteins.
So there's no preference in
nature for synthesizing one
over the other, but somehow,
somewhere, a long time ago,
there was a preference given
to the L-enantiomer.
And so all of us have the
L-enantiomer present in the
proteins in our bodies.
So I'm going to say only, but
you know that there's always
going to be some
exception here.
But by and large, only the
L-enantiomer of amino acids
found in proteins.
And you're going to see the
protein synthesis in a moment,
and try to figure out
why that happened.
By the way, carbohydrates,
which we're not
going to talk about--
carbohydrates are
chiral as well.
And in sugars, only the
D-enantiomer of amino acids
found in sugars.
And you'll see later, this is
all important in terms of a
lock and key mechanism.
And there are some L-sugars.
L-sugars you know as
invert sugars.
And our bodies don't recognize
Our body apparatus requires
that there be D-sugars.
There's some science fiction
novella I read many years ago
about this group of people
that's marooned on the
proverbial desert island, and
it's lush with vegetation, and
they're eating all of these
fruits and vegetables and
wasting away.
And at the end of the novel, it
comes to be known that this
island, because it was isolated,
somehow, back in
time, the plant life there had
the opposite enantiomer, and
so their biological apparatus
didn't recognize anything.
They were eating all this stuff,
and it was just going
right through them with
no nutrient value.
So if you're ever
marooned, check!
Find out which enantiomer
you're eating!
Otherwise you're wasting
your time.
Honey has the L-sugar, because
bees have a different
biological apparatus.
Now, when we synthesize these
things chemically, we can get
both enantiomers coming out of
the synthetic apparatus unless
we take pains not to.
And so when both enantiomers
are present, we call that
specimen, that's term racemic.
So you have both the
dextrorotatory and
levorotatory present.
Now, normally we take the five
minutes at the end to talk
about chemistry in the world
around us, but this is, you
know, day before Thanksgiving
holiday, and we've got a
natural entry point here.
I want to talk about what the
consequence here is for human
health that drives directly
from chirality.
About 40 years ago, there was
a drug developed in Europe
called thalidomide.
And it was developed by a German
firm called Chemie
Gruenenthal.
If I can just spell it.
And it was developed as
an anticonvulsant.
And it was a sedative, and it
had fantastic properties.
Namely, that it was something
that you could use in
treatment of people who are
very depressive, but they
couldn't kill themselves
with this.
If you tried to overdose with
thalidomide, you would simply
go into a sleep, and then
you could be rescued
Well, that was its original
intention.
Just by accident, it was
discovered by various people
who were using it that it was
a very fine palliative for
morning sickness.
And so women started using it
in the first trimester of
their pregnancies in order to
calm their morning sickness.
And so there were calls for the
importation of this drug
to the United States.
And the FDA said no.
And of course there was an
outcry from women's groups
that said, oh, the FDA is just
a bunch of men that are
insensitive to women's
health issues.
Let's speed this stuff up,
let's get it over here.
They're using it in Europe.
What are we doing?
It turns out that this was
during the time of President
John Kennedy, and he had
appointed the first woman
director of the FDA.
And she said, it hasn't been
tested thoroughly.
We're not importing it
to the United States.
People got on airplanes,
they used post
office, what have you.
They brought it into the United
States, and it was used
widely in the United States,
And then subsequently was
discovered that this is a
teratogen, which causes severe
mutation of the DNA,
and children
being born minus limbs.
There were grotesque
deformities.
And so the position of
the FDA was right.
So you say, well, but didn't
they test this stuff?
And they did.
Well, didn't they test
it on animal models?
And they did.
Turns out the animal models
that they used lacked a
certain enzyme that's present
in our bodies, that converts
thalidomide downstream into
something that's a teratogen.
It's a really, really
sad story.
It turns out now, knowing what
we know, only one of the
enantiomers of thalidomide
causes birth defects.
Not both.
So racemic thalidomide was
loaded with both palliative
and toxic components.
And so this is a powerful
lesson of getting the--
avoiding the toxic enantiomer.
And also, there may be
people here who are
opposed to animal testing.
And I understand
your concerns.
But we're far from being able
to sit with the Shroedinger
equation and a supercomputer
and predict the metabolic
activity of these drugs.
And so this is the dilemma
for people.
Do you want to test it or not?
Do you want to get
these things--?
It's actually coming back now,
in the treatment of HIV-AIDS.
It's being used as part of
a cocktail with other
medications.
But now we know not to give the
racemic form, but only to
give a particular enantiomer.
Another one that is a chiral
molecule is Ritalin, which is
used, among other things, for
the treatment of ADHD.
And there are some negative
side effects
of the use of Ritalin.
And again, it's being discovered
that it's only one
of the enantiomers that has
the negative side effects.
And so the whole question of
chiral molecules is a very,
very hot topic in chemical
research.
And so, how do you how direct
the synthesis to get to one
enantiomer and not the other?
Catalysis.
Again, which is something that
is very important and not very
well understood.
Highly empirical, still.
So all of those lessons
that we've
learned are very important.
I think there's a cartoon here
that actually shows--
all right, so here's
the example.
This is a molecule
that's chiral,
and it's very primitive.
You've got a square and
a triangle and a
circle and so on.
And you see, both of these
have the same chemical
properties.
But when you're looking at this
in terms of biological
activity in the human body, you
can think about a lot of
these interactions
as lock and key.
Now, there aren't these
little holes here.
It's not putting a square peg
in a round hole versus what
are they really trying
to model here?
They're trying to model the
types of secondary reactions.
So for example, there could be
a polar center here, and this
could be charged negatively,
and this could be charged
positively, and so they will
be attracted coulombically.
Maybe this has a polar end,
and this has a dipole, and
they'll be attracted.
Maybe this is nonpolar, and this
is nonpolar, so they all
fit, whereas if you turn it
around, you've got something
that's positively charged
here, and this thing's a
dipole, there's no adhesion.
So that's where this
lock-and-key
idea comes into play.
And so what we're going to do
later on is to figure out how
to match things up in terms of
dipole-dipole interactions,
coulombic interactions,
and so forth.
OK.
So what are the properties
now?
Let's look at the properties
of these things as just
straight chemicals.
So we had amino acid, I had the
solid neutral form of the
amino acid.
What are its properties?
Not the protein.
Properties of the amino acid.
OK.
So first of all, they are solids
at room temperature.
And why would we do that?
Well, because look.
You've got hydrogen bonding
capability here, and that
hydrogen bonding capability
allows it to form bonds great
enough to overcome
thermal energy.
Molecules like this, do you
think they form crystalline
solids or amorphous solids?
They're small enough that--
this one looks a lot like
methane, doesn't it?
Looks like methane with a
couple of extra things.
But from a distance,
it's a sphere.
maybe A little bit oblate,
but it's a sphere.
So these things form crystalline
solids as opposed
to amorphous solids.
Their optical properties,
I've already shown you.
They're colorless.
They're not good absorbers.
Where's the covalent bonds
with tight electrons?
So there's no reason to have
excitation and color.
And then, they're moderately
soluble in water.
And that water chemistry
is what we're
going to turn to next.
So now I want to look at how
they behave in water.
And where I'm going with this
is to show you the first
stages of how we
animate matter.
Because I talk about
inanimate matter.
We are animate matter.
Where does the animation
come from?
What's the chemical origin
of our animation?
How is it that I can do this?
See, you're looking
at changes in the
conformation of a polymer.
That's all you're doing.
You're saying, well, how--
he's moving fast. What's
the Debye frequency?
It's 10 trillion
times a second.
10 trillion times a second the
atoms vibrate in my body, and
the speed at which I'm rotating
my hand, compared to
10 trillion times a second,
very slow, right?
Which actually explains why we
talk at the speed we do.
And why is it that a human
being can only run--
or not only run, but runs at the
speed that he or she does?
It has to do with
the chemistry.
With the Debye frequency, and
what the skeleton can do--
I mean, why aren't human
beings 40 feet tall?
I mean, stand back here
and-- all right--
we're going to create
this universe.
Why are we this tall, and
not 40 feet tall?
Because make a skeleton 40 feet
tall would be chemically
very difficult.
It's all chemistry.
The rest, as we know,
is stamp collecting.
OK, so now let's look at
the properties of the
amino acids and water.
So I'm going to write them again
in a different form.
So here I'm going
to put the H2N.
Here's the amino acid N.
Here's the central carbon.
And I'm going to put the
hydrogen, instead of writing
it down here, this
is the carbon
with its little hydrogen.
This is the carboxylic
acid N, and then the
substituent group is above.
So this is again the thing.
By the way, there are two
carbons here, agreed?
And the central carbon is also
known as the alpha-carbon.
This is the alpha-carbon.
That's the beta-carbon, I bet.
All right.
So now what I'm going to do is,
I'm going to dissolve this
in water at neutral pH.
And what happens?
What happens is that once this
thing solvates, the proton
falls off the carboxylic end and
comes over and attaches to
that electron pair at
the amino acid end.
And we end up with this,
at neutral pH.
H3NCHCOO, and the substituent
is a spectator here.
Well, I lost a proton, so this
is locally negative.
And I gained a proton with
its charge over here.
So this is locally positive.
I conserve charge.
This is not neutral and this is
not neutral, but it has a
negative end and a positive end,
and it's not a dipole.
I mean, this is negative
ion-like and
this is positive ion-like.
So let's say, net neutral
locally positive and negative.
And just as we've fallen in
love with some German
terminology for words like
bremsstrahlung, we have a
German word for this one.
This is like a twin ion, or it's
like a hermaphrodite dual
gender, so this is called
zwitterion.
It's got both genders,
if you like.
It's positive and negative.
OK.
So there's zwitterion.
And this is the way
that we start to
introduce the dynamic behaviors.
So now I'm going to show
you how to make
something come to life.
So what we're going to do, is
we're going to show how this
zwitterion can respond to
changes in its environment.
And we're going to invoke in
order to do is to say that to
impart animation, we invoke the
le Chatelier principle.
It's sort of like Newton's
third law for chemistry.
You know Newton's third law.
Every action, there's
a reaction.
So le Chatelier was a French
engineer, but his name is
associated with an important
chemical principle.
And it basically says that if
you disturb a chemical system,
the chemical system will respond
in such a way as to
minimize the disturbance.
So the example I'm going to give
is, I'm going to start
with a neutral pH, and I'm
going to change the pH.
And then the zwitterion is going
to respond to minimize
the disturbance.
In other words, if I drop the
pH, zwitterion is going to try
to raise the pH back to
what it was before.
And in doing so, I think you're
going to start to see
how we can get animation.
So it's sort of like that
a chemical disturbance--
this is the le Chatelier
principle.
Chemical disturbance
is mitigated
by a chemical response.
So here's the example that
we're going to use.
We're going to say, let's
take something and
radically change the pH.
So let's drop the pH.
So drop a pH means, the
proton concentration
is going to go up.
So how would zwitterion respond
if it wants to reduce
the proton concentration?
Well, it's going to try to
gobble up the protons.
Well, how's it going
to do that?
Well, we know that there's
a proton attachment site.
Look, there's a proton
attachment site at the
carboxylic acid end.
How do we know?
Because it used to have
a proton there.
So it's going to go and vacuum
up protons to try to bring the
pH back to what it was before.
So let's look at
that reaction.
So here's H3NCHCOO minus plus.
So this is neutral zwitterion.
And what it's going to do in
response to the increase in
proton concentration is try
to gobble these up.
And the following
is the result.
That proton is now going to
attach here, and cap that
negative end.
So now we've got a proton on
this end, and we've added a
proton at the other end.
So what's happened to the
neutrality of zwitterion?
It's lost!
Now zwitterion is net positive,
but we've started
gobbling up protons.
So this reaction is called
protonation.
And the reverse reaction
is deprotonation.
And this is messy, all these
darn characters.
So I'm going to write the
neutral zwitterion as just HA.
There's the proton here,
and the rest of this
stuff is just details.
So that's A.
So HA plus H plus gives me this
thing here, which is HAH
plus there.
Isn't that cleaner?
That's a lot easier to read.
And we can write an equilibrium
constant for that reaction.
I'm going to call
this reaction 1.
In reaction 1, I can write K1.
And it's written, the convention
is that you always
write the reaction
constant for the
deprotonation reaction.
So I'm going to write the
reaction constant for this
reaction from right to left.
So that's going to be this.
H plus over HA divided by
concentration of HA H plus.
And then we're going to bring
Sorensen to the party, and
take logarithms, and make
it nice and clean.
As we know, when Sorensen
enters the room, he
straightens things out.
And so this will then become PK,
and if I take the log base
10 of this, I'm going to end up
with minus log base 10 of
H, which then will be PH.
And then this flips over with
the minus sign, and becomes
log base 10 of the ratio of
protonated zwitterion over
deprotonated zwitterion.
And this is known as the
Henderson-Hasselbalch equation.
And what does it answer?
It answers the question, you
tell me what the pH of the
system is, and I'll tell you
what the ratio of protonated
to deprotonated is, because
the PK is the
function of the R group.
So different R groups have
different PKAs, and they'll
respond differently.
Some are very aggressive, and
some are not so aggressive.
And look at what happens.
At one end, when we have neutral
pH, we have all of the
zwitterions sitting here.
And as we go to higher and
higher pH, more and more of
the neutral zwitterion converts
to the protonated
zwitterion.
And in the extreme, when I've
got very, very high proton
concentration, I will protonate
all the zwitterion.
I'll protonate it out
of existence.
And the only amino acid that
exists is fully protonated.
So I've got a sliding scale from
100% deprotonated to a
100% protonated.
Well, somewhere along
this scale is 50-50.
And what happens when I've got
equal amounts of protonated to
deprotonated?
That means the concentration
of protonated equals the
concentration of deprotonated.
I have the log of 1, which is
0, and that's the pH at PK1.
So now you see physically
what PK1 means.
It's the pH at which you're
halfway in between, which
makes sense.
If I wanted to characterize
something, it has values
between 0 and 100, I'd give you
the value at 50, and you
know, it varies around 50.
Either 50 plus 50,
50 minus 50.
So that's what the PK is.
Good.
Now let's do the same thing
for the opposite side.
Let's, instead of a sudden drop
in pH, let's look at a
sudden rise in pH.
Now you see, just to
finish the point.
Look at what happens here.
What I'm trying to show you is
that this change in pH caused
this molecule to change.
you I mean, this could
be in your stomach.
And now you drink some coffee,
or you drink some cola, and
the pH goes way, way down,
because you've drunk something
that's acidic.
Well, there are functional
groups in the lining of your
stomach that are going to
now start protonating.
And when they protonate, they're
going to change.
This could have been bonding
to something, right?
COO minus could've been bonding
to some other molecule
that's locally plus.
When the proton comes
in here and caps it,
that bond is broken!
And that's the beginning
of animation.
So that when I drink something,
and all of a
sudden, my stomach
goes into action.
Well, we're going to have
to process this stuff.
Have to turn on some
switches here.
It's not my brain
that's doing it!
It's not that the brain gets
all these sensor signals.
We couldn't function that way.
We're functioning just by these
things acting right
there at the site.
This is the origin
of animation.
I'm telling you that this
is the secret of life.
I can't tell you the
meaning of life.
You have to go somewhere else
to answer that question.
But I can tell you where
life comes from.
There it is.
So now, sudden rise in pH, this
means that the proton
concentration goes way down.
See, zwitterion is like one of
these friends you might have.
Do you have any friends
that are, what do
you call them, rescuers?
You know, if they see anything
wrong, they're the ones that
get involved?
They've got to help
everything?
In the extreme, they're
quite meddlesome.
Well, this is what zwitterion
is like.
See, zwitterion sees a sudden
drop in pH and goes, I'm
zwitterion!
I can help!
I know what to do, because
I'm zwitterion!
I fix things!
And I'm conflict-averse,
I don't like this!
OK.
Imagine you are zwitterion.
So here's zwitterion, sitting
there, minding its own
business
[BREAK IN AUDIO]
PROFESSOR: --for a minute.
Why?
Because it's in a neutral
pH solution.
Minding its own business.
That's a chemical joke.
All right.
So there's zwitterion,
just sitting there,
minding his own business.
And all of a sudden, the pH
rises, and the proton
concentration drops.
So now we've got an abundance
of hydroxyls.
We're in an aqueous solution.
So the zwitterion looks around
and says, I've got to fix
this, but there's no hydroxyl
attachment site!
So the zwitterion can't gobble
up the hydroxyls.
So what's the zwitterion
do instead?
Instead, it starts
shedding protons.
Because if it sheds protons,
then what can happen is, if it
forms this plus proton, then
the proton can react with
hydroxyl to form water, and then
shoot the pH back to near
neutrality.
So let's dump the proton here,
and we'll just end up with H2
and CHCOO minus with
the R group.
So this is deprotonation in
order to address the sudden
rise in pH.
And now we can write a K2.
Let's call this reaction 2,
and with K2, since it's a
deprotonation reaction right
away, we can just go ahead and
write, this is going
to be H plus.
And what's left?
This is just a denuded,
deprotonated zwitterion, just
the A minus, all over
neutral zwitterion.
And it looks like this.
And we can invoke Sorensen and
get PK2 equals pH plus log
base 10 of the neutral
zwitterion over the
deprotonated zwitterion.
And there you go.
And then, of course, that
50-50 concentration of
deprotonation, the pH gives
you the value of PK2.
And now, at one end,
I get deprotonated.
The other end, I get
fully protonated,
right in the middle.
I get the 100% zwitterion.
I said at neutral pH, but
that doesn't mean 7.
It means the pH at which this
particular species is stable.
And that's different from
7, and it's somewhere in
between, isn't it?
Because if I go to very
acidic solutions, I
will start to protonate.
If I go to alkaline solutions,
I'll deprotonate.
So somewhere in between.
And that somewhere in
between is called
the isoelectric point.
The isoelectric point
is the place at
which we get the neutral.
So that's HAmax.
The concentration of this is
maximal at the isoelectric
point, and that's called P sub
I, and that's given by PK1
plus PK2, divided by 2.
And that's it.
You don't have to run it.
We're done.
Thank you.
OK.
So this is the simple story.
It gets more complicated if, for
example, the R group can
protonate or deprotonate.
So now we got two or
three-ring circus.
It gets more interesting.
But this is the start, and
there's some homework problems
that will help you
muddle through.
OK.
So I think this is a good place
to switch into the final
five minutes.
So here's the titration curve.
I'll show that at the beginning
of the next lecture.
OK.
So now let's talk
about kinetics.
And the extreme in kinetics,
I said, is an explosion.
And we're coming upon December
6, which is the anniversary of
the largest explosion in the
history of the world before
the nuclear age.
And it occurred in 1917, and
Halifax Harbor, Canada, at
that time was a British colony,
and therefore Canada's
foreign policy was dictated
by Britain, which was
involved in a war.
And there was a French supply
ship and a relief ship, and
they collided in
Halifax Harbor.
This is what the French
supply ship had on it.
Notice 20,000 tons of TNT.
At 8:45 AM, the Mont-Blanc
is hit by the Imo.
But the TNT was not ignited,
and instead we ended with
sparks and a fire.
By the way, this is TNT.
If you look, this is toluene.
Toluene is methylbenzene.
It's just the methyl group.
And this is trinitrotoluene.
And if you go to Wikipedia,
Wikipedia gives this formula,
which is wrong.
The methyl group is
missing here.
Just a word to the wise.
Be careful when you use
that tool, I put
in quotation marks.
Because it's worth about as much
as you pay for it, which
is why we teach you to use
the bibliographic things.
OK, so there it is,
right here.
I didn't make this up.
Look at this.
Completely wrong.
Anyway, so what happens?
"The crew of the Mont-Blanc,
aware of their cargo,
immediately took the lifeboats,
screaming warnings
that no one heeded.
They rode for Dartmouth"--
this is across the channel
from Halifax--
"leaving the now furiously
burning ship to drift towards
Halifax, propelled in that
direction by the Imo's impact.
The Mont-Blanc drifted by a
Halifax Pier, brushing it and
setting it ablaze.
Members of the Halifax
Department responded quickly,
and were positioning their
engine up to the nearest
hydrant when the Mont-Blanc
disintegrated in a blinding
white flash, creating the
biggest man-made explosion
before the nuclear age."
It was 9:05 a.m.
on a Thursday morning.
"Over 1,900 people were
killed immediately.
Within a year, the figure
climbed to well over 2,000.
Around 9,000 were injured,
many permanently.
325 acres, almost all of North
End Halifax was destroyed.
Much of what was not immediately
leveled burned to
the ground, aided by what are
stockpiles of coal in cellars.
As for the Mont-Blanc, all
3,000 tons of her were
shattered into little
pieces that were
blasted far and wide.
The barrel of one of her cannons
landed three and a
half miles away.
Part of her anchor shank,
weighing half a ton, flew two
miles in the opposite
direction.
Windows shattered 50 miles away,
and the shock wave was
felt even in Sydney, on Cape
Breton Island, 270 miles to
the northeast.
"There was about 20 minutes
between the
collision and the explosion.
It was enough time for
spectators, including many
children, to run to the
waterfront to watch the ship
burning, thus coming
into close range."
I mean, they were little kids,
and it's a fire, and the fire
engines are coming!
It's fun!
It's more interesting than
going to school, right?
"It was enough time for others
to gather at windows.
Office workers came to the
windows, and with the
explosion, the glass shattered
and blinded them.
"Not surprisingly, the hospitals
weren't able to cope
with so many wounded.
There was also a desperate
need for housing, and the
misery was compounded"--
are you ready for this?--
"by the blizzard that struck
the city the following day,
dumping 16 inches of snow
over the ruins.
"With astounding speed, relief
efforts were set in motion.
Money poured in from as far away
as China and New Zealand,
Canadian Government gave--"
blah, blah, blah.
"But most Haligonians"--
which is what you call a
denizen of Halifax--
"most Haligonians remember the
generosity of the state of
Massachusetts, which donated
$750,000 of money and goods,
and gave unstintingly in
volunteer assistance through
the Massachusetts Halifax
Relief Committee."
People from the hospital
district here got on trains,
and went up there to assist,
especially from Mass Eye and
Ear, to assist the people
that had been blinded.
"Starting in 1971, to this day,
Halifax sends an annual
Christmas tree to the city
of Boston in gratitude."
And there are specifications on
what the tree should look
like, and how big it should be,
and so on, and they bring
it over to Boston Commons.
So if, in the days that come,
when you get back from
Thanksgiving, if you happen to
be across the river and you
see something that's about 45
feet high and it looks like it
came from Canada, this
is what it is.
And it's all about the
Halifax explosion.
OK.
There you go.
All right.
Well, have a nice weekend.
We'll see you on Monday.